[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
convicted murderer robert durst is
sentenced to prison time you got nothing
else to do do something right once and
finally how long the real estate air
will spend in prison and the death of a
mod aubry
we bring you up to speed from the first
gunshot to next week's opening day of
trial plus from the white house to the
big house why former trump adviser steve
bannon could spend time behind bars and
later how do you wish to plea guilty the
accused parkland school shooter enters a
guilty plea we look ahead to nicolas
cruz's penalty phase law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law on crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin nearly 21 years after susan
berman was found shot to death in her
beverly hills home her best friend
robert durst is sentenced to life
without parole for her murder
law and crimes angie levy is here with
what happened at sentencing and why
durst's legal troubles may not be over
brian that sentence of life in prison
without the possibility of parole really
it was a foregone conclusion no surprise
there since robert durst was found
guilty of first-degree murder with
special circumstances now durst did not
speak during that sentencing hearing in
los angeles you may recall he did a lot
of talking when he was on the stand he
was up there for nearly 14 days and he
admitted to lying during his testimony
but
insisted he did not kill susan berman
prosecutors argued that durst killed
berman to silence her about the
disappearance of his first wife kathy
she disappeared in 1982 and her body has
never been found susan berman's loved
ones spoke to the judge at sentencing
i was robbed and my beautiful son was
robbed of an
absolutely extraordinary unforgettable
brilliant
person
whose life was savagely taken from her
at 55 when she had many years ahead all
i can attempt to tell you is what life
has been since my mother's murder
it has been a daily soul-consuming and
crushing experience
since my mother's murder there has not
been one day that i've not lived that
this has not been at the center of every
thought feeling choice
or breath i take
i have not had
one day off in almost 21 years from the
absolute destruction
grief or pain that this has caused me
now news 12 out of new york has been
reporting that the westchester county
district attorney's office will soon
start presenting evidence to a grand
jury
against robert durst in the death and
disappearance of kathy durst and i've
reached out to the westchester county
da's office to try to confirm that
information
so far i have not heard back from the
spokesperson there meanwhile robert
durst's attorney dick degarin tells
along crime that he's only heard
rumblings like we have about this grand
jury but he said if that grand jury is
fair that robert durst will not be
indicted brian
thanks angenette joining us today is
defense attorney bruce marquette and
terry austin bruce the defense made 15
last ditch efforts by filing motions
after the verdict but ultimately durst
was sentenced is this case final or do
you see any appeals
well there certainly will be an appeal
he's got a life without parole sentence
so that undoubtedly he'll appeal it
sounds like mr durst is going to be a
full
uh employment opportunity for lawyers
into the future in new york in
california
um and perhaps in louisiana as well this
was the case if you recall where they
used a full-length video
to
present to the jury and i say video i
mean made for television movie because
somehow it provided some adaptive
admission to
the prosecutor i i thought that was an
outrageous abuse of discretion i think
that that alone may end up
causing a reversal of this conviction
absolutely now
terry we saw this sentence coming but
what did you make of the judge's final
words to durst
i thought judge windham was really
fairly straightforward during the
sentencing he patiently listened to
those motions but i think at the end he
ultimately said that he got to know
susan berman and he felt bad about that
loss and then ultimately he did sentence
him to life in prison without the
possibility of parole and anger did any
of the jurors attend the sentencing
yeah it was really interesting brian
jordan chacon one of our producers here
at long crime she said she recognized at
least five jurors and she said that it
appeared they had family members with
them as well and she said that those
jurors were really kind of hanging on
every word as the family members of
susan berman spoke and really as the
judge spoke so
it was interesting they obviously were
interested to see what would happen at
the sentencing and you can you know tell
obviously from them attending that they
are invested in this case emotionally it
went on for four or five months the
trial did yeah thank you for that
insight anjana of course thank you
jordan for being there to give us that
reporting and on to other top legal news
former minnesota police officer kim
potter may claim the shooting death of
dante wright was a quote innocent
accident in april potter shot and killed
a 20 year old at a traffic stop potter a
26 year old veteran of the police force
said she was going to use a taser but
instead shot right with a gun in a court
filing on thursday potter said she may
use one of the following defenses in the
death innocent accident or innocent
mistake her perceived use of the taser
was a reasonable or lack of causation
potter is facing manslaughter charges in
wright's death her trial is set to begin
on november 30th
and a florida man is charged in the
death of his girlfriend after their
two-year-old son shot and killed her as
she made a zoom call for work
twenty-one-year-old shamaya lin died in
august after her son found an unsecured
handgun and pulled the trigger officials
say the gun belonged to 22 year old the
andre avery lynn's boyfriend and the
toddler's father court documents show
avery kept the weapon in a backpack
decorated with animated characters from
a children's show at the time of her
death lynn was on a zoom call with
co-workers one of them called 9-1-1
after her shoot after hearing shooting
saying she quote heard a loud noise and
the child in the background began to cry
avery was charged with two counts this
week failed to securely store firearm
and manslaughter
still ahead in online crime daily the
accused parkland school shooter expected
to enter a guilty plea for the 2018
school massacre not before his guilty
plea and a jail battery case but first
the timeline of events leading up to
ahmad aubrey's death what to expect in
the coming trial
[Music]
it was the video that shocked the nation
an unarmed black jogger 25 year old
ahmad abre gunned down in broad daylight
we are going to make sure that we find
justice in this case the three men
charged will now stand trial i told him
stop stop stop till he hit me i had
nothing to do
there's nothing else i can do you're a
passer buyer coming through not
necessarily
that's my son that shot him i was at the
back of the truck
starting october 18th watch live capital
gavel coverage on the law and crime
network
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
nearly two years in the making a trial
will finally begin with a jury selection
on monday for the death of a mod arbory
ahead of jury selection law and crime
daily's sierra gillespie breaks down the
timeline of the case
brian in the nearly two years since the
death of a mod aubry the case has taken
many twists and turns complete with what
some call delayed arrests graphic viral
video and recused district attorneys as
all eyes move to georgia for next week's
jury selection we take a look back at
where it all began his name was ahmad
aubry he was 25 years of age
he was a resident here in brunswick
georgia he was involved in athletics
liked play games outside he liked to run
i like to play video games for ahmad
aubry february 23 2020 was just another
day but only two miles from his
brunswick georgia home
[Music]
the gunshots heard round the nation
paired with a chilling cell phone video
that shows a once physically fit 25 year
old suddenly keeling over in the middle
of the road i don't believe it was
self-defense by mr mcmichael i believe
it was self-defense by mr aubry blake mr
albert was in pursued
and he randomly couldn't run anymore
and it would turn him back to a man with
a shotgun or
or fight with his bare hands against a
man with a shotgun he chose to fight
video taken from william roddy bryan
shows father and son duo greg and travis
mcmichael tailing aubry with a pickup
truck eventually firing shots that would
be fatal the mcmichaels would tell
police they chased arbory down because
they believed he was responsible for
break-ins in their neighborhood from the
interior video of the house you see him
just wandering around again not taking
anything the father and son claim when
they approached aubry he attacked travis
mcmichael who fired his weapon in
self-defense that's my son that shot him
i was in the back of the trail
i need to get this blood off my hand
after that travis mcmichael stands over
arbory's body as he dies making racial
slurs
mr brian said that
after the shooting took place
before police arrival while mr aubry was
on the ground
that he heard travis michael make the
statement
by late february 2020 the brunswick area
district attorney jackie johnson would
recuse herself from the case saying
gregory mcmichael was an investigator in
her office for more than 30 years before
his 2019 retirement by april a second
prosecutor would recuse himself after
defending the actions of the mcmichaels
and brian one month later the cellphone
video of arbory's shooting circulates
online creating national outrage days
later gregory and travis mcmichael are
arrested jackie this is great did you
call me as soon as you possibly can
i've been involved in the shooting and i
need some advice
two weeks later brian is also arrested
and charged with murder and criminal
attempt to commit false imprisonment
when bodybuilding
inspired the two other men
to kill my youngest son days later the
department of justice begins an
investigation into arbory's death as
well as two da's who recuse themselves
from the case by november jackie johnson
is voted out of office days later a
judge denies bond for the mcmichaels in
april 2021 a federal grand jury indicts
the mcmichaels and brian with hate
crimes and attempted kidnapping a month
later arbory's accused killers plead not
guilty to those federal hate crimes in
august 2021 a judge orders arbury's pass
run-ins with the law cannot be used by
the defense three days later former d.a
johnson is indicted on charges related
to the arbory death investigation at the
start of october 2021 a judge rules
arbory's past mental health records
cannot be used as evidence by the
defense team when the case goes to trial
the federal trial of gregory and travis
mcmichael and william roddy bryant is
set for february 7 2022. the state trial
in the death of ahmad aubry is set to
begin on monday stay tuned to law and
crime network for complete gavel to
gavel coverage of the case and a day by
day breakdown for long crime daily i'm
sierra gillespie
thanks sierra let's bring back criminal
defense attorney bruce marquette and
terry austin to break down the two
defenses in this trial terry the
citizens arrest defense how do you make
take the false imprisonment sorry and
the felony murder charge and fight this
in this type of case and will it work
well the defendants are going to try to
argue that this was a reasonable
detention under the prior citizen's
arrest law you could argue that you
could detain someone if you just were in
the presence of that crime or you had
knowledge about that crime governor kemp
actually tried to overhaul it so it
wasn't a vigilante type law and he did
overhaul it but still businesses and
individuals homeowners can still say
that this was a reasonable detention to
protect their properties so the real
question here brian is whether or not
this was a reasonable detention under
the new law absolutely bruce the
mcmichaels have claimed that this was
self-defense that travis was protecting
himself when aubry fought him for his
gun does that argument mean not guilty
here
that seems to be uh no it shouldn't mean
not guilty it's the only thing they can
argue there is a portion of the video
where you can see
how aubry fighting with the individual
with a gun but what we have what we know
is that before that happened he was
chased down by these individuals and
confronted so he had a choice to either
continue to run away from a pickup truck
or to fight the person with a gun and he
chose the ladder and got shot to death
alvary was the one who was trying to
defend himself uh look the defense has a
tough job they have to say something so
they'll make that argument but i do not
think he'll be successful
all right we'll see how it plays out
those being the two main defenses a
citizen's arrest that they perceived or
thought that arbor is committing a
felony in their presence or self-defense
that's what the defense is going to
present in this case and like sierra
said make sure to check the law and
crime network for gavel to gavel
coverage as that case begins next week
coming up on law and crime daily nicolas
cruz will likely plead guilty to the
parking school shooting but first he
enters a guilty plea on separate charges
plus the consequences for former trump
adviser steve bannon and the role he
played in the january 6 capital riots
all that and more after the break
[Music]
welcome back former trump adviser steve
bannon could face a hefty fine or time
behind bars as a so-called january 6
committee pursues it pursues criminal
charges all this is in relation to the
capital riots that occurred on january
6th the house select committee in charge
of investigating the january 6 attacks
requested bannon provide details about
conversations he had with former
president donald trump they say those
conversations happened leading up to the
riots banning claims that since trump
signaled he would fight the committee's
efforts he is not required to respond to
the subpoena the select committee will
vote next week on whether to adopt a
contempt report if passed it will be
brought to the full house from there the
washington d.c district attorney would
bring the matter before a grand jury
bannon faces the possibility of a fine
or up to a year in prison if he refuses
to cooperate with the committee's
demands
back to break down the latest in the
january says committee investigation is
criminal defense attorney bruce
barquette and co-host terry austin bruce
subpoena's contempt of court break those
down for us especially in the
congressional uh setting and how does it
work out if bannon doesn't play ball
well first we have to draw a distinction
between the two right contempt of court
is one thing people get subpoenaed to go
to court if they don't show up the judge
can issue a material witness order and
have them arrested and brought to court
and forced
uh to testify if they refuse to testify
held in jail until they comply this is
contempt to congress which is different
they have to go through a process a
committee has to vote on it the whole
entire house has to vote on it nancy
excuse me uh nancy pelosi has to uh
certify it and then it has to go to the
justice department and one i guess the
democrats hope that they enforce this uh
referral and actually prosecute the
contempt case so mr bannon is months
away from uh having to face the music so
to speak all right so we'll see how that
plays out terry bannon said he would
ignore the subpoena because of an
executive privilege does that mean
congress can't subpoena him then
no not at all i mean they've already
subpoenaed him clearly they have the
right to do that and the fact that he
refused to show up for this deposition
they've already said they're holding him
in contempt so he was scheduled to
appear he failed to appear and as we
just heard he can
absolutely be subject to
the doj if in fact the full house votes
as the committee has already indicated
that this should be something where he
is held in contempt of court i think
ultimately this is going to go to the
doj and i do think that ultimately
merrick garland is going to give some
sort of view on it as to whether or not
bannon should be held in contempt there
are others who are talking to the house
and so they have been postponed for now
all right we'll see how it plays out as
bruce said this is a long
road not a short one so as we get
updates we'll make sure to give you them
when we come back a guilty plea from the
person who pulled the trigger in the
parkland florida shooting the court
appearance from nicholas cruz where he
plead guilty to attacking a law
enforcement officer what comes next for
the accused parkland shooter
[Music]
welcome back guilty on all charges
that's the plea accused parkland shooter
will likely enter for the 2018 school
massacre on friday he entered a separate
guilty plea for a 2018 jail battery
incident nicholas cruz is charged with
the murders of 14 students and three
staff members from the marjory stoneman
douglas school shooting cruz now 23
originally wanted to plead guilty for
the crimes in exchange for life in
prison without parole prosecutors were
persistent in pursuing charges though in
order to secure a death sentence for the
accused school shooter cruz is now
expected to plead guilty for all 17
counts of attempted murder and all 17
counts of premeditated murder from that
day that means he will skip trial and
move straight to the penalty phase where
jurors will decide his fate on monday
cruz was set to begin a trial for the
2018 battery charges after prosecutors
say he attacked a jail guard on friday
crews pled guilty to those charges
opting to go straight to the penalty
phase
14129 to count one of the information
attempted aggravated battery on a law
enforcement officer with a deadly weapon
how do you wish to plea i plead guilty
count two battery on a law enforcement
officer how do you wish to plea guilty
count three depriving an officer means
of depress protection how do you wish to
plea guilty and count four attempted use
of self-defense weapon against a law
enforcement officer how do you wish to
please her guilty
i accept your plea of guilty i find that
you are alert and intelligent that you
understand the nature of the charges
that you understand the consequences of
entering into the plea i find that you
have made an informed decision with the
advice of counsel and that you're
knowingly voluntarily and intelligently
waiving all of the rights that i just
went over
all right bruce i get why this is good
for the government the victims and their
families don't have to relive this but
is there an advantage for the defense to
admit guilt and move straight to the
penalty phase
this case for the defense has always
been about the penalty phase the only
thing that they're trying to do is save
this individual's life they don't want
him to be executed the strategy involved
as to whether or not to go through a
trial and try to begin to lay the
groundwork for your penalty phase
defense or to forego the trial and go
right to the penalty-based defense is a
tough call for lawyers facing these
kinds of cases there's obviously no
factual dispute about whether or not he
killed the individuals the only question
would be whether or not he has some kind
of defense along the lines of a mental
disease or defect or something like that
that they could begin to explain to the
jury why he did this in an effort to
save his life
usually you go through the penalty of
the guilt phase first almost no matter
what because you give the jury the
opportunity to stay guilty and to deny
you something
here they've decided to go
uh straight to the penalty phase it's a
risky
strategy but i'm guessing they may have
good reasons for it we'll see all right
we'll see if it plays out risky indeed
terry what's the penalty phase in a
crime this heinous going to look like
and do you think cruz will avoid the
death penalty
you know that's a really good question
the death penalty is still on the table
and that is right bruises bruce is
absolutely right they are trying to
avoid the death penalty for cruz here
and i think we're going to see multiple
witnesses for both aggravating and
mitigating circumstances for the
mitigating circumstances we might just
hear about his mental state for the
witnesses who will testify about
how they have been impacted remember we
had 17 people killed and 17 people
injured so i think we will get a number
of witnesses who are going to talk about
what this loss meant to them so i do
expect that it will be a very difficult
phase of the trial and i do expect that
the government will still try to keep
that death penalty right front and
center all right we'll see how that
plays as it comes up thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you